Die ganze Liga kann komplett nervös werden. Wir werden das nicht. In dieser Folge entlässt niemand seine Trainerinnen. Versprochen. Über die neuesten Entwicklungen in der 2. Liga, den Hamburger SV und Eintracht Braunschweig spreche ich jetzt mit Thomas Hürner von der SZ und Thomas Löwe vom Eintracht Podcast gegen gerade.
Und nun im Programm der Rasenfunk.
Lagerheim fliegt vorbei und der Ball ist im Tor. Und Augsburg ist oben. Rossi ist zu kurz ab, der lang genug für Willi Landgraf. Marc-Graf, Martin Marc-Graf.
Und das 1-0.
Markus Kurt aus dem Gewühl. Alexander Schur!
Der Blick auf andere Ligen.
Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, was für zwei Wochen oder was für eine Woche auch schon. Ich denke, keine Liga auf dieser Welt hat so viel Geltungsbedürfnis wie die 2. Liga der Männer hier in Deutschland. Gut, außer ich vielleicht mit meinem Zwang in jeder Folge hier, egal wie und wann, einmal meinen eigenen Verein zu nennen. Sorry, not sorry. Ich hoffe wirklich, die Strichlisten existieren. Ich bin Eva Lottabolo und ich begrüße euch sehr, sehr gerne zu einer neuen Ligatour zur 2. Liga. Und bevor ich meine Gäste begrüßen darf, ein ganz kleines bisschen Housekeeping. Denn der Rasenfunk ist und bleibt werbe-, payone- und sponsorenfrei, finanziert sich ausschließlich durch eure Spenden. Und lieben Dank an alle, die bereits Rasenfunk-SupporterInnen sind und vielleicht auch die, die es noch werden möchten. Aber an die, die es sind, da geht es stellvertretend heute ein Dank raus an Einarinho, Tillmann SCF, Marta aus Freiburg, Globara Night, der unterstrich Bohem und Gigi1985. Und in dem Zug auch nochmal die Erinnerung. Bitte denkt ganz, ganz, ganz doll an die Kontoumstellung des Rasenfunks. Und dass ihr nicht mehr ganz so viel Zeit habt, eben die Kontoverbindung zu ändern für eure Daueraufträge. Infos dazu auch nochmal in den Show Notes. Außerdem sind ganz, ganz viele Sendungen online. Unter anderem ist auch heute eine Ligatur noch zur europäischen Ligen entschieden. Es erscheint noch ein Schwerpunkt zu Bayer Leverkusen. Also ihr habt bis zum Wochenende ganz, ganz viel nachzuholen. Jetzt kann man aber starten. Und ich hoffe einfach jetzt schon, dass es nicht zu wahnsinnig großer Verwirrung kommt. Denn ich habe jetzt direkt zwei Thomas in diese Sendung eingeladen. Ich sag gleich noch, wie wir das gleich im Verlauf der Sendung regeln, damit ihr als HörerInnen und ich auch nicht so verwirrt werde. Zum einen darf ich mal wieder Thomas Hürner in dieser Runde begrüßen. Ihr kennt ihn bereits als Nordexperte und vom SZ Podcast und nun zum Sport.
Hallo Thomas.
Hi, freut mich.
Ja, und dann darf ich zum ersten Mal im Rasenfunk Thomas Löwe begrüßen. Da schon mal kleiner Hinweis. Im Folgenden einfach nur Löwe genannt. Es passt einfach zu 100 Prozent. Das zweite Gesicht, ja, kann man so sagen, das Gegengrade Podcast neben Anna Lautenbach. Hallo Thomas. Hallo Löwe. Schön, dass du auch dabei bist.
Hallo Eva. Herzlichen Dank für die Einladung. Ja, heute müsst ihr mal mit mir vorleben nehmen, sonst seid ihr Anna gewohnt, die das ja in ihrer gewohnt charmanten Art macht. Ja, Löwe passt gut, weil Nachname ist Löwe, Braunschwecke Löwe und so haben wir diesen Konflikt mit dem Namen einmal aufgelöst, denke ich.
Genau, als wäre es für diese Episode extra gemacht worden.
Quasi.
Bevor wir auf eure beiden Vereine blicken, wollen wir natürlich einen Blick auf die Lage der Liga werfen und ich habe schon gesagt, meine Güte, ey, da war ja kein Tag ohne Pause dabei gefühlt. Ich habe euch mal eine kleine Chronologie der Ereignisse mitgebracht. Also, was wir schon wissen und was ihr schon von der letzten Folge wisst, am 15.04. entlässt der SC Paderborn oder beziehungsweise nicht entlässt, sondern gibt bekannt, dass Lukas Quasseniok nach der Saison nicht länger Trainer beim SC Paderborn ist. Am 22.04. trennt sich der FC Kaiserslautern von Markus Anfang, Torsten Lieberknecht übernimmt. Am 23.04. verkündet Schalke 04, dass Kees van Wonderen am Ende der Saison den Verein wieder verlässt. Nachdem ja tagelangen Gerüchte dazu im Unlauf waren und vorher war eben auch Frank Baumann als neuer Sportvorstand am 1. Juni oder ab 1. Juni nie verkündet worden. Ebenfalls am 23.04. trennt sich Janova 96 mit sofortiger Wirkung von Andrej Breitenreiter, Lars Baalemann, Dirk Lottner und Christian Schulz übernehmen interimsweise. Aber das war es noch nicht, weil hey, wir haben ja auch alle nichts zu verarbeiten an News neben dem ganzen Fußball. Am Sonntag, den 27.04., trennt sich dann auch noch Aufsteiger Preußen Münster nach fünf Jahren von Sascha Hildmann und ist damit auch der dritte Aufsteiger, der im Prinzip den Trainerwechsel dann noch hinten raus verkündet. Interimstrainer werden Christian Panda und Keren Schulze-Marmeling. Und ja, das ist der Sohn von Dietrich Schulze-Marmeling. Löwe, mal als erstes die Frage an dich. Gab es aus dem ganzen Konglomerat irgendwie so eine Trainerentscheidung, die dich so ein bisschen, ja doch ein bisschen aus dem Sessel gehauen hat vielleicht?
Aus dem Sessel gehauen haut mich da gar nichts. Also gerade wenn es so in die Crunchtime der Liga geht, da ist immer alles möglich. Da wird noch mal so, wie man es auch schon sagt, die letzte Patrone noch mal in den Lauf des Revolvers geschoben. Das ist dann immer das schwächste Glied, die Trainerentlassung. Ein paar Dinge wie auf Schalke ist wahrscheinlich so, ja eher von langer Hand vorbereitet, also nicht so eine Affekthandlung, wir müssen jetzt unbedingt was machen. Ja, Quasenjörg hat mich schon auch so ein bisschen überrascht, muss ich sagen. Also nicht vom Hocker gehauen, aber schon überrascht, weil der eigentlich auf Patrborn hervorragende Arbeit gemacht hat. Aber auch da sieht es mir so aus, ja als ob, weil Patrborn vielleicht ein ganz so ein bisschen die Luft ausgeht, jetzt im Endspurt, dass das vielleicht auch noch mal zu der Entscheidung entweder mit beigetragen hat oder er persönlich aber was anders machen wollte. Ich kannte jetzt die genauen Hintergründe eigentlich nicht mehr so genau. Also zusammengefasst, so richtig vom Hocker gehauen, nein, ob das in jedem Einzelfall so eine ganz schlaue Wahl ist, das ist immer eine ganz andere Frage.
Thomas, wie sieht es da bei dir aus?
Ja, ergänzend vielleicht zu Lukas Quasniok, den habe ich tatsächlich Anfang des Jahres mal für ein Portrait getroffen. Eigentlich ganz feiner Typ und die Trennung hat mich am allerwenigsten überrascht, ehrlicherweise. Also das war eigentlich, es ist einfach seine Ambition, dass der jetzt was anderes macht. Die waren schon vergangenen Winter auf der Zielgeraden, übrigens auch in konkreten Verhandlungen damals mit dem HSV gewesen. Das heißt, das bahnt sich schon sehr, sehr lange an und sein Branchenruf ist hervorragend, auf fachlicher Ebene auf jeden Fall. Und ja, es ist eine Frage der Zeit, wo er in der ersten Liga coacht oder eben auch einen größeren Club coacht als den SC Paderborn. Nichtsdestotrotz will er jetzt natürlich alles irgendwie noch in die Wege leiten und versuchen, mit dem qualitativ nicht gerade hochwertigsten Kader im Aufstiegsrennen eine Rolle zu spielen. Aber da du nach der Überraschung gefragt hast, ursprünglich, also wahrscheinlich Breitenreiter, hätte ich jetzt irgendwie nicht gedacht, weil es ja da auch nicht mehr irgendwie ganz, ganz konkret um den Aufstieg geht. Bei Hannover habe ich das Gefühl, trotz des Sieges jetzt am Sonntag, aber die Liga, da werden wir wahrscheinlich nochmal darauf zu sprechen kommen, ist ja sowieso irgendwie eine Art Verstoß gegen den Glücksspiel-Staatsvertrag oder so.
Ich habe auf diesen Verein natürlich einen sehr speziellen Blick, Thomas. Deshalb mit einem leicht gehässigen Unterton. Nein, das hat mich nicht überrascht, weil das ist so typisch dieser Verein, völlig aus dem Nichts in die Träne rauszuschmeißen. Das ist so für mich auf der Überraschungsskala 1 bis 10, eher so eine 3 vielleicht gewesen.
Ich muss halt irgendwie sagen, bei Breitenreiter, also wir hatten es hier ja auch damals in dem Hannover-Segment diskutiert, weil ich schon damals verstanden habe, warum man sich irgendwie von Leiteln getrennt hat. So weil man eben diesen 3-Jahres-Plan in Gefahr gesehen hat. Aber ich habe es damals halt schon nicht verstanden, warum man dann ausgerechnet Breitenreiter geholt hat. Und das haben wir ja auch besprochen. Also so eine richtige Entwicklung war ja auch ehrlich gesagt einfach nicht zu sehen unter ihm, warum man es jetzt dann macht. Und ich checke dann sowieso immer nicht, was ist seit der letzten Länderspielpause passiert so ungefähr, wo ich mir immer sage, naja, wenn du wirklich nochmal einen Impuls setzen willst, in dem Sinne dann mach es doch da. Und also gerade bei Hannover siehst du ja schon länger dieses Stagnieren in gewissen Zügen. Also das fand ich dann auch irgendwie einen komischen Zeitpunkt. Ich glaube, Markus Mann meinte auch so, ja man will jetzt halt doch nochmal alles reinwerfen. Gut, da ist halt auch einfach die Sache. Also wir sehen es in dieser Liga. Du kannst halt nicht nur auf dich gucken. Also das wird nicht funktionieren bis hinten raus. Also liebe Grüße da an den User Kaya aus dem Forum, der glaube ich gesagt hat, also realistisch gesehen oder statistisch gesehen brauchst du 56 Punkte für die Relegation. Davon ist Hannover 10 Punkte weg. Wir können das alle ausrechnen. In drei Spielen ist es nicht machbar. Selbst wenn alle anderen für dich spielen. Da ist es weg. Ich glaube, das kann man so klar sagen. Und deshalb, ja, ich checke es auch nicht so ganz. Also davon abgesehen, dass es natürlich auch vertaglich auch Kohle kostet. Hannover ist sowieso immer ein eigenes Thema. Ich muss halt sagen, Preußen Münster fand ich doch den Zeitpunkt etwas merkwürdig. Also ich glaube, es hieß noch, es gab letzte Woche Dienstag eine Aussprache, ein Team treffen, etc. Und irgendwas, also die haben halt 1-1 gegen Darmstadt gespielt. Naja, das ist für die Punkte zu wenig. Aber wenn du dir Darmstadt in den letzten Wochen und Monaten anguckst, ist das jetzt auch kein Weltuntergang irgendwie. Da muss halt irgendwas vorgefallen sein. Also sowas, was man hört, gerade die Beziehung zu manchen Spielern war nicht die beste. Ich kenne es bei uns halt nur, weil Johnny Godrowski ja von Münster nach Bielefeld gewechselt ist und was man über den Wechsel so hört. Da ist auch nicht alles rund abgelaufen. Von daher wirkt von außen natürlich immer so bitter, dass dann so ein Aufstiegstrainer, der dann auch noch fünf Jahre da war, dann für die letzten drei Spiele irgendwie zu entlassen. Ja, also ich bin mal gespannt. Aber sie haben natürlich auf jeden Fall noch Chancen auf den Klassenerhalt. Aber so, was ich so gesehen habe, waren da die Fans auch größtenteils nicht gerade happy drüber. Aber wir werden sehen. Es war ja auch fußballerisch noch ein bisschen was los. Und Thomas, fang doch gerne mal an, gab es da ja so ein Ergebnis, wo du sagst so oder in einem Spiel, wo du gesagt hast, ok, krass, dass das so ausgeht oder dass das vielleicht das oder das passiert. Das hat mich dann auch ja, ich bleibe immer bei überrascht. In dieser Liga überrascht dann ja weniger mehr. Aber trotzdem vielleicht ist bei dir hängen geblieben.
Also, wie du schon sagst, überraschen tut mich jetzt in der Liga wirklich echt gar nichts mehr. Das klingt irgendwie auch so ein bisschen platt, aber es ist echt so. Spannend fand ich tatsächlich, dass Elbersberg eben dann nochmal in der Nachspielzeit gegen Paderborn ausgeglichen hat. Da werden auch in Hamburg einige Leute durchgeatmet haben, weil es natürlich dann ja den Abstand nochmal irgendwie beibehalten hat oder nicht hat weiter schrumpfen lassen. Dann ansonsten ja, wie gesagt, irgendwie in ihrer Verrücktheit kommt es dann diese Liga.
Löwe, wie sieht es bei dir aus?
Also nicht überrascht, aber vielleicht so ein bisschen auf längere Sicht. Überrascht hat mich schon, dass das 1 zu 0 von Ulm in Fürth, für uns ja eh nicht so ein ganz freundliches Ergebnis. Fürth hatte ja, die waren auf dem absteigenden Ast, dann hatten sie sich wieder gefangen. Jetzt greifen sie nochmal aktiv in den Abstiegskampf mit ein. Ulm eigentlich Riesenrespekt, weil die immer, die werden bis zum letzten Atem zu kämpfen, wenn man das mal so ausdrücken will. Die beißen sich da immer wieder rein, gewinnen dann immer wieder überraschend Spiele und Punkte. Die hören einfach nicht auf. Das ist für Eintracht lästig, aber sie haben Riesenrespekt bei mir, dass sie da Fürth jetzt mal unten mit reinziehen. Aller Bonheur.
Fürth ist jetzt glaube ich auch seit mehreren Spielen auch dann doch sieglos hinten raus. Es ist irgendwie auch so ein bisschen verhext mit denen. Ganz liebe Grüße gehen da raus an Michael Fischer. Ich glaube, der verzweifelt at this point ein bisschen, weil er sich das natürlich auch jede Woche angucken muss. Aber ja, also ich finde es schon spannend da unten drin. Du hast halt irgendwie Fürth, Braunschweig, Ulm, Münster, Regensburg. Ich habe ja noch ganz oldschool die Tabelle ausgedruckt. Habe ich mir mal gegönnt für heute, weil einfach diese Liga so komplett durchgeknallt ist. Aber ja, also es ist irgendwie immer, du hast dann doch diese Ergebnisse, wo du denkst, okay, wo kommt das jetzt her? Und gerade Ulm, also werden wir später auch noch mal drüber reden, dass es für Ulm am Ende noch um so viel gehen könnte, dann doch. Wird natürlich auch spannend für den HSV dann hinten raus noch, wenn man gegen die spielt. Ob das jetzt von Vorteil oder von Nachteil ist, ist halt so die Frage. Aber also noch mal zu dieser ganzen Prognose im Ausstieg hin. Also wir haben jetzt vier Mannschaften mit 49 Punkten. 4. Elversberg, Paderborn, Düsseldorf und Lautern. Düsseldorf, die... keine Ahnung. Ich glaube, also dieses 3-3 gegen Nürnberg fühlt sich für Düsseldorf am Ende wie ein Sieg an, für Nürnberg wie eine Niederlage. So, weil für Nürnberg bedeutet das automatisch dann doch als endgültig. Ja, okay, mit dem Aufstieg wird es wahrscheinlich nichts werden. Also man ist jetzt fünf Punkte weg vom Relegationsplatz. Wir haben es eben gesagt, 56 Punkte ist so realistisch, weil halt die Mannschaften auch irgendwie alle noch gegeneinander zum Teil spielen und so. Und du halt 3-0 führst und dann kommt Düsseldorf irgendwie zurück. Also komplett abgefahren noch irgendwie. Aber, honorable mention für das Nürnberger Sondertrikot zum 25. Jubiläum, das am Sonntag, glaube ich, ist, am 4.5. Sehr schönes Video auch dazu, habe ich euch mal verlinkt. Und Take Notes, Frau Verlossener Brück. Ich weiß nicht, wer es von euch gesehen hat, aber die haben ein Sondertrikot zur Maiwoche rausgebracht. Und das ist, also ja, ich weiß, ich bin da auch biased, aber das ist wirklich mit das Furchtbarste, was ich in den letzten Jahren gesehen habe. Das euch vorstellt, so ein lilanes Trikot und dann ist da in so groß so ein Pieces-Zeichen abgedruckt. Ist vollkommen in Ordnung, ne? Message ist ja die richtige Umsetzung, würde ich so eine freundlich gemeinte 4 Minus geben.
Was hälst du denn vom Wiesentrikot der Bayern? Das wäre jetzt die Frage.
Äh, ich hab's glaube, das werden so viele Sondertrikots immer wieder vorgestellt. Ich glaube, ich fand das letzte ganz schick. Ich finde, also man muss auch sagen, ist halt Adidas, ne? Also Sondertrikots können sie meistens. Das ist so, ich war zuletzt nicht überzeugt von ihren Sondertrikots zum Teil. Also weil sie gefühlt einfach die EM-Trikots genommen haben, vor allem die Torwart-Trikots gesagt haben, die betreibt ihr jetzt alle. Aber nee, also war schon ganz schick. Ich meine, es liegt eh immer im Auge des Betreifters. Diese Osnertrikots waren sowieso trotzdem sofort ausverkauft, diese limitierte Stückzahl. Es liegt immer, ist Geschmackssache. Ich fand es trotzdem besonders hässlich. Lass es mich einfach so formulieren. Aber gut, bevor wir jetzt, außer ihr habt noch irgendwas zur Lage der Liga?
Also kurz auf dieses Spiel in Düsseldorf kann man ja schon eingehen. Das war ja schon krass. Ich meine, da liegen die 3-0 hinten, dann machen die noch ein 3-3. Also ich liebe sowas ja.
Ja, vor allem, ich muss sagen, mir hat halt Nürnbergs Konterfußball enorm gut gefallen. Also das war halt schon, ich glaube, sie können auch höher führen zum Teil schon. Aber es war sehr schön gemacht. Da gibt es, glaube ich, jetzt die Diskussion, hatte ich auch im Forum gelesen, und Chimas, der ja irgendwie wohl, also in Anführungszeichen Muskelprobleme hat. Da gibt es, glaube ich, so ein bisschen die Gerüchte, ob das schon etwas mit seinem Wechsel zu Brighton zu tun hat, also dass er sich davor nicht mehr verletzen soll. Gut, kann man interpretieren, wie man möchte, at this point. Aber ja, generell, also Düsseldorf ist aber so eine Mannschaft, die mich sowieso immer, ja, keine Ahnung, die hinterlässt immer Fragezeichen hinter mir. Also wir haben da vor einem, ich glaube ja vor einem Monat oder so über die gesprochen. Und das ist ja klar voll gut, dass sie sich da zurückkämpfen, aber dass sie sich überhaupt in diese Lage in einem Heimspiel bringen, ist halt, boah, weiß ich nicht, hat mich jetzt auch nicht, also.
Das ist komisch. Fehlt denen so der letzte Punch? Ich weiß nicht, meine gut, das trifft irgendwie auch fast alle Gruppen irgendwie geradezu. Daniel Thun ist ja wirklich ein toller Trainer, aber so das letzte Quäntchen fehlt immer.
Ja, sie kriegen halt überdurchschnittlich viele Gegentore irgendwie, also und schießen dafür dann halt fast zu wenig, um da halt noch ein paar Tabellen, also mit 51 Toren und 46 Gegentoren. Gut, hast du immer noch besseres Torverhältnis als Kaiserslautern, aber halt ja auch nicht viel, also, weiß ich nicht. Es ist ja eine Sache noch zu Schalke 04, weil dann natürlich bleibt es darum auch nicht, ja, leise. Also Kaiserslautern, du bist ja der einzige, das haben wir jetzt zu wenig gewürdigt, die einzigen aus diesem Top, ja, also mit den 49 Punkten, die auch wirklich gewonnen haben dann. Mit 2 zu 1 gegen Schalke 04, mal wieder Ragnar Ache, ja, so lustig auch.
Endlich mal wieder getroffen hat, ja.
Ja, genau, er hat ja wohl auch eine Wette am Laufen mit Thorsten Lieberknecht. Aber natürlich sprechen wir dann weniger über Kaiserslautern am Ende, sondern Schalke 04. Da gab es nämlich wieder eine Suspendierung. Ivan Barcock wurde suspendiert wegen einer Snapchat-Story. Man muss einfach die heutige Welt lieben. Sachgemäß oder sinngemäß hatte er eine Story gepostet von seinen unbenutzten Schuhen und fehlerfrei geschrieben und daraufhin meinte ein Fan zu ihm, dass das vielleicht nicht die klügste Art und Weise wäre, während man gerade ein Spiel verloren hatte. Und da hat er daraufhin den Fan beleidigt. Die Worte möchte ich ungern wiederholen und wurde deshalb suspendiert. Es bleibt halt auch einfach nicht ruhig auf Schalke. Aber natürlich, Kaiserslautern. Löwe, ich muss dich noch einmal fragen, wie komisch wäre es, wenn Kaiserslautern jetzt mit Torsten Lieberknecht nochmal so ganz, ganz nah an den Ausstieg drankommt?
Überhaupt nicht komisch. Ich würde ihm das sehr gönnen. Ich bin weiterhin ein Riesenfan von Torsten Lieberknecht. Also jeder kennt ja nun seine Braunschweiger Vergangenheit. Einmal 10 Jahre Trainer bei uns, Spieler bei uns gewesen. Hat uns nach 28 Jahren zurück in die Bundesliga geführt. Ganz, ganz, ganz feiner Kerl. Ich durfte ihn im Rahmen einer Spezialserie in meinem Podcast als Gast haben. Dem gönne ich alles Gute in dieser Welt. Ich glaube, er ist auch der Richtige. Man hat ja auch gesehen, Kaiserslautern noch mal zu kitzeln, um dann noch mal ins Aufstiegsrennen einzugreifen. Ich fände es wunderbar, wenn er das erneut mit dem 3. Verein auch noch mal schaffen würde.
Ja, ich fand es auch eine sehr, also die Persona an sich, dass Kaiserslautern das schon wiederbringt, nachdem sie Marco und Werden damals entlassen haben, für die vor den Relegationsspielen zur 2. Liga, um Dirk Schuster zu holen, La Liga er es noch kennt. Das war ja, also machen sie jetzt zum zweiten Mal. Ja, könnte man wahrscheinlich auch darüber reden, was da wieder im Hintergrund lief. Das ist halt, ja, weiß ich nicht, ob sie damit hinterher Recht behalten. Ich finde es trotzdem von außen komisch. Da muss ja auch wieder eben das vorgefallen sein, dass wir so nicht wissen. Aber gut, jetzt wollen wir aber wirklich auf unsere Vereine kommen oder eure Vereine kommen und starten da beim Hamburger SV, weil er der höher platzierte Verein ist, auch wenn man manchmal sich da nicht so ganz sicher ist bei der Stimmungslage da gerade. Es ist Platz 2. Es sind 53 Punkte, 66 zu 40 Tore, 14 Siege, 11 Unentschieden und 6 Niederlagen. Und es ist eben ein Punkt hinter Köln auf Platz 1, drei Punkte Vorsprung auf Magdeburg auf Platz 3 und der Trainer, der ist weiterhin mehr in den Polzin. Ja und die Stimmung, wie gesagt, die ist jetzt so semi-gut, würde ich sagen. Es gab eine Niederlage gegen Karlsruhe am Wochenende, nur vier Siege seit wir das letzte Mal über den HSV hier gesprochen haben, Mitte Februar. Und unter anderem eben auch Niederlage gegen Paderborn und Braunschweig, nur unentschieden gegen Elbersberg und Regensburg. Thomas, du bist nah dran am Verein. Was ist denn da gerade los beim HSV?
Oh, das ist schon wieder gefühlt so vielschichtig, dass man nicht genau weiß, wo man anfangen soll. Also, da du jetzt das KSC-Spiel angesprochen hast, ich habe jetzt auch ein bisschen was erlebt im Fußball, gesehen, gerade auch mit dem HSV allerlei Verrücktheiten. Aber so ein Spiel habe ich, glaube ich, wirklich noch nie erlebt. Also, die gehen da rein in einer tabellarisch privilegierten Position, die ja eigentlich noch dieselbe ist, die du gerade eben aufgezählt hast, weil sich da ja so gesehen nicht so viel verändert hat. Und du hast von der ersten Minute lang den Eindruck und das Gefühl, dass da kein Spieler und ganz wenige auch dann auf den Tribünen und so an den Aufstieg glauben. Das war wirklich so kurios. Und ich glaube auch, ich bin nicht der Einzige, der diesen Eindruck dann aus diesem Spiel mitgenommen hat. Und das ist natürlich höchst problematisch, wenn man sich jetzt nochmal auf den Saison-Endsport begibt.
Aber woran liegt das denn? Weil du hast es ja schon gesagt, die Lage war gut. Ich meine, klar, die wussten zu dem Zeitpunkt noch nicht, dass Köln gegen Hannover verliert. Aber ich meine, man konnte ja die restlichen Ergebnisse sehen, eigentlich nur unentschieden drum herum. Also mit einem Sieg hättest du ja fast schon sagen können, vielleicht noch nicht rechnerisch, aber das wäre natürlich für den Kopf ein unfassbar wichtiger Sieg gewesen.
Absolut. Man kann eigentlich fast nur noch zu dem Ergebnis kommen, dass dieser ganze Club, dieses ganze Umfeld eine Art Angst vor dem Gewinnen hat. Also es war wirklich von der ersten Minute anzugreifen, wie wieder die Nervosität und ich würde es auch Angst nennen, irgendwie um sich gegriffen hat. Wie da einfachste Pässe einen halben Meter neben den Fuß gespielt werden. Wie da wieder nochmal sich umgedreht wird, statt nach vorne zu spielen. Wie da wirklich komplett der Faden verloren wird. Und wie man gegen einen Gegner, der mit relativ einfachen Mitteln da reingegangen ist, einfach dann überhaupt kein Konzept mehr entwickelt und überhaupt keine Stabilität und Sicherheit mehr. Das hat man dann eben auch bei den Gegentoren gesehen. Also die waren Pech, Slapstick und individuelle Fehler in einem. Und das in dieser konzentrierten Form in der Saisonphase so auf den Platz zu bringen, ist schon einfach wirklich kurios. Und es folgt ja jetzt ehrlich gesagt, muss man ja auch sagen, ein Muster. Also Löwe hat das Spiel mit Sicherheit dann eben auch gesehen. Dieses 2-4 in Hamburg gegen Eintracht Braunschweig. Dann ein Spiel auf Schalke, wo man glaube ich 88 Minuten in Überzahl spielt. Und trotzdem eine 2-1-Führung her schenkt. Und das wirklich auch wieder auf absurde Art und Weise. Und auf absurde, ja auch mit einer absurden Haltung. Dann irgendwo auch zu diesem Spiel. Diese Spiele an sich erzählen alle eine eigene Geschichte. Aber ich habe irgendwie und ich bin glaube ich nicht der Einzige. Ja, ich würde es eine Befürchtung nennen. Also jetzt einfach aus HSV Perspektive, dass sich da jetzt irgendein Fehler in diesen Quellcode oder so geschlichen hat, den man ja den man jetzt irgendwie rausbringen muss und von dem man sich nicht sicher sein kann bei diesem Verein, dass man den rausbringen kann.
Ist das Thomas aus deiner Sicht ein Bruch tatsächlich doch ausgelöst durch das Spiel gegen meiner Eintracht oder ist das so ein stufenweiser Aufbau? Weil gegen KSC, das hatte ich auch gesehen, das war wirklich schlimm. Also als Fan muss das auch wirklich richtig schlimm gewesen sein. Oder war das so ein Knackpunkt da, wo dann doch der Kopf ansprang, auch wenn das Davy Selke zum Beispiel nach dem Spiel gegen Braunschweig vehement bestritten hat, gesagt, er hat überhaupt keine Angst und es geht weiter und keine Ahnung was, strahlte da auch eine gewisse Sicherheit aus. Aber nistete sich das dann doch im Hinterkopf ein? Wir haben diese Historie, fängt das schon wieder an? Wie bewertest du das?
Davy Selke ist tatsächlich wahrscheinlich genau das falsche Beispiel, weil er der einzige in meinen Augen ist, der wirklich druckresistent ist in dieser Mannschaft. Deswegen ist er auf seine Weise leider nicht repräsentativ. Es gibt zum Beispiel viele Kollegen von mir, die waren sich vor dem Braunschweig-Spiel 100% sicher, also die haben wirklich gesagt, 100% die gehen hoch, die sind so klar in dem, was sie tun. Die haben das auch noch nach dem Braunschweig-Spiel gesagt. Ich war da immer so ein bisschen skeptischer, habe gesagt, sobald der Moment eintritt, an dem dieses labile Gebilde zum Überlegen kommt und zum Nachdenken und ja auch vielleicht ein bisschen zum Zweifeln, was noch alles schiefgehen kann, wird es einfach extrem gefährlich. Und dann kam eben noch obendrauf dieses Schalke-Spiel, wie gesagt 88 Minuten Überzahl und wo dann auch und ja, Merlin Polzin, der Trainer, hat es wirklich sehr, sehr lange sehr, sehr gut gemacht. In diesem Spiel im speziellen setzt er aber dann den besten Torschützen, den wie ich schon sagte in meinen Augen einzigen druckresistenten Spieler, also wirklich, wirklich druckresistenten Spieler in diesem Kader auf die Bank. Erklärt das mit taktischen Erwägungen und dahingehend ist es halt schon ganz interessant. Das Trainerteam ist wirklich auch sehr offen. Es holt sich viele Ratschläge ein. Es hat, so wie ich gehört habe aus guter Quelle, eben auch sich bei jungen, modernen Trainern nicht diese alte Garde umgehört, die sowas schon hinter sich gebracht haben. So die letzten fünf, sechs Spiele. Was ist da zu tun? Der HSV ist zum Beispiel auch in einem Trainingslager gewesen, inzwischen zeitlich, einfach nochmal um den Teamspirit zu stärken. Aber was sie zurückgespiegelt bekommen haben, ist, es ist wirklich völlig egal, ob du jetzt in 2, 3, 4, 1, 28 Muster aufbaust oder wie die Laufwege dann sind. Ich überspitze das jetzt. Es kommt einfach auf Klarheit an. Es kommt darauf an, die Spieler zu stärken, auf die du dich verlassen kannst. Es kommt einfach auf Resilienz an und es wird keine guten und ansehnlichen Fußballspiele mehr geben. Und dann macht Merlin Polzin so etwas auf Schalke, wo er komplett entgegen der eingeholten Ratschläge handelt. Und dieses Spiel hat, glaube ich, wirklich was verändert dann auch in den Köpfen. Und das hast du einfach beim Karlsruhe-Spiel enorm gesehen, gespürt, wahrnehmen können. Das war wirklich einfach kurios. Ich kann mich nur wiederholen.
Ich finde, es gibt so eine Stimme voll mit ein, was ich von außen beobachte oder was ich auch lese und höre von anderen HSV-Fans. Ich glaube, man darf nur eine personelle Sache nicht ausblenden, das ist Miro Mouheim, der jetzt ja schon seit drei Wochen verletzt fehlt. Er ist ja nicht nur einfach Linksverteidiger, sondern er bringt ja so eine gewisse Spielmacherkomponente, gerade in Zusammenarbeit mit Luc Dompe oder Jean-Luc Dompe mit, der hat ja auch gerade seinen Vertrag verlängert. Aber du merkst halt, dass er fehlt. Da auf dieser linken Seite, Paul Zin hat ja auch vieles versucht, ich glaube, erst Hefti, der wurde dann schon nach 45 Minuten durch Reiß entsetzt, dann Mikkel Broncys. Du siehst es ja, wenn du jetzt HSV-Spieler siehst, du merkst ja komplett, Dom P steht total häufig irgendwie im leeren Raum. Da fehlt zum Teil einfach komplett diese spielerische Idee, die sie auch mitbringen. Und ich glaube, also da wird jetzt interessant sein, ich las noch heute auch einen Kicker-Artikel, da hieß so ein bisschen, wie viel Zeit bekommt Muhaym noch, um gesund zu werden, so nach dem Motto. Wie siehst du Muhaym in dieser ganzen Konstellation? Oder sein Wegfall?
Ich kann dir da völlig beipflichten. Man könnte jetzt kritisch anmerken, so abhängig von dem Linksverteidiger zu sein, ist jetzt auch nicht gerade gesund. Und was ich dann auch eben auch nochmal kritisch anmerken würde, mit Blick auf Polzin, dann muss man eben die Spieler auch entsprechend der Stärken und Schwächen einsetzen. Also auch immer wieder, Silvan Hefti, ein eher eindimensionaler Fußballer, würde ich sagen, mit klar verteilten Stärken und Schwächen, der ist dann auch im KSC-Spiel ständig invers im Spielaufbau beteiligt gewesen. Und das Spielsystem und die einstudierten Matchpläne entgegen solcher Komponenten durchzudrücken, ist gerade in der Saisonphase auch einfach nicht ratsam. Und das hat man gesehen, das hat Unsicherheit gestiftet, der hat sich da sichtlich nicht wohlgefühlt. Und nochmal, also das ist dann teilweise, ich möchte jetzt auch nicht überhaupt Merlin Polzin zu sehr in Zweifel ziehen, weil die Gründe auch gerade kaderbedingt sehr, sehr tief liegen. Aber dann muss man halt ganz, ganz konsequent eben, ja, Stärken fördern und Schwächen probieren abzumildern.
Ich finde es halt trotzdem, also wir reden ja schon fast so, als wäre der HSV rausgerutscht aus diesen Ausstiegsplätzen. Also es ist gar nicht so, ich finde das irgendwie immer so krass, weil du hast ja trotzdem immer noch drei Punkte Vorsprung auf Magdeburg. So du hast eben den Vorteil, dass alle drum herum auch so ein bisschen schwächen. Aber ich glaube, du merkst halt echt, also wie gesagt, alles, was ich höre, also alles, was ich quer gelesen habe, was ich von HSV-Fans höre, es ist bei allen überall dieses. Dritter Platz ist das Maximale, was wir diese Saison noch erreichen können. Und das ist halt, ich glaube halt wirklich auch, das ist irgendwann so eine Wechselwirkung. Weil natürlich setzt sowas irgendwann auch vom Stadion auf die Mannschaft über und so vice versa. Also alles, was ich von Leuten aus dem Stadion gehörte, Thomas, ist genau das, was du gesagt hast. Das ist einfach so diese komplette Fassungslosigkeit in genau diesem Moment der Saison so raus. Weil ich habe das hier schon zu einer Stelle gesagt, ich habe gar keinen Bock mehr auf diese Frühlingswitze und so. Irgendwie musst du es ja schaffen. Und ich weiß, dass ich eigentlich bei Melli Polzin gesagt habe in der letzten Rasenfunk-Folge, so habe ich eigentlich gesagt, boah, ich glaube, der hat so einen psychologischen Vorteil. Der ist nah am Verein dran. Der weiß, wie es war die letzten Jahre. Die haben einen guten Plan, da läuft viel richtig. Und dann, das Spiel direkt danach war das 1-1 gegen Regensburg. Und das war so, das war für mich fast der Knackpunkt, weil du da so das erste Mal das Gefühl hast, oh, oh, jetzt gehen diese Spiele los. Gehen diese Spiele gegen die da unten, die man irgendwie unbedingt gewinnen muss. So, ne, und das ist, ey, keine Ahnung, das ist die, so, wir haben jetzt gerade geguckt, okay, es gibt spielerische Komponente, aber der Kopf, den kriegt man da nicht raus. Und man muss ja einfach sagen, also, sie haben die meisten Tabellenführungen in der 2. Liga. Das sind acht Stück. Zwischen dem 28. und 29. Spieltag waren sie eigentlich immer wieder Tabellenführer. Seit dem 29. ist es eben der FC Köln. Und es gab eigentlich immer so einen ständigen Wechsel zwischen den beiden. Und es ist irgendwie– also Köln und HSV, ich glaube, du findest keine 2 Vereine in dieser Liga, bei der gerade schlechtere Stimmung herrscht. Also korrigiert mich, wenn ich da falsch liege. Ich habe das Gefühl, egal ob du Köln, die wollen seit ungefähr 80 Jahren das Struber weg ist. Also das ist ja absurd. So und dann hast du den HSV. Ich glaube noch nicht mal, dass die irgendwie sagen, ja okay, Polzin soll weg. Aber die einfach sagen so, wie kann das denn sein, dass wir uns schon wieder in dieser Lage befinden, dass wir schon wieder Angst haben müssen, obwohl man das Gefühl hat, es läuft. Eigentlich lief es so lange so gut wie lange nicht mehr.
Ich würde da nur eins ergänzen sozusagen. Also am Sonntag war es definitiv so, dass das von der Mannschaft aus ging und nicht vom Publikum. Also das war dann schon irgendwann weiß versa, aber das ging ganz klar von der Mannschaft aus, von den Spielern und ich habe es von Anfang an auch für einen großen Fehler gehalten. Also Stefan Kunz, als er Sportvorstand wurde, eben zu Beginn dieser Saison, hat ja so als Maßgabe gehabt, Nuancen zu verändern, aber auf dem aufzubauen, was ihm da von Jonas Bold hinterlassen wurde. Und ich habe jetzt auch nie dafür politiert, irgendwie 17 Spieler rauszuschmeißen, aber die Teamhierarchie musste einfach anders gebaut werden. Also Jonas Meffert hat zu Genüge nachgewiesen, dass er diesen Situationen einfach nicht gewachsen ist. Sebastian Schonlau hat neben mentaler Komponenten oder Defizite nachgewiesen, dass er auch sich auf der Zielgerade als Zweitleger-Verteidiger befindet. Und wenn du mit der Teamhierarchie in diese entscheidende Phase gehst, ist das halt einfach problematisch. Das hat man gesehen. Der Wieselke ist tatsächlich so das beste Vermächtnis von Steffen Baumgart. Das war nämlich mehr oder weniger sein Transfer. Also das war jetzt nicht so, als hätte der Sportdirektor Klaus Koster diese Idee initial entwickelt. Und wie du schon sagst, also ich habe jetzt auch nochmal geguckt, wann war eigentlich wirklich das letzte gute Fußballspiel des HSV. Das blendet man ja auch fast ein bisschen aus. In meinen Augen war es der 3-0-Sieg gegen Magdeburg. Das war Mitte März. Zwischenzeitlich hat man auch mal 3-0 in Nürnberg gewonnen. Das wird auch von vielen als Signal oder als Beleg für die Klarheit aufgeführt. Aber letztendlich war man da, glaube ich, auch nach 15 Minuten oder so in Überzahl, hat komplett vom Spielverlauf profitiert. Und das natürlich auch gegen eine total volatile Mannschaft. Also der 1. FC Nürnberg, ja, mein Gott, wenn die einen schlechten Tag haben, dann haben die einfach einen verdammt schlechten Tag. Und das ist halt einfach, ja, und seitdem, ja, wirklich Dürre eigentlich, auch was die Leistungen angeht. Und das ist halt mit Blick auf die letzten Spiele schon sehr bedenklich, weil man kann ja trotz des Vorsprungs nicht ausschließen, also es wird ja immer argumentiert, ja, okay, die nehmen sicher der eh alle Punkte weg, so. Aber du kannst ja trotzdem nicht ausschließen, dass Marke-Dolkenburg jetzt einfach noch mal drei gewinnt. Oder dass irgendjemand einfach noch mal diesen zwei, drei Spiele-Run hat, den man einfach eben nicht ausschließen kann und den es in der Geschichte der zweiten Liga zu Genüge gegeben hat. Und wenn der HSV jetzt am Samstag in Darmstadt, wo ich dann auch hinfahren werde, wenn die da wieder nicht gewinnen oder wenn die sogar so desolat auftreten, erneut wie gegen den KSC, dann halte ich wirklich auch sämtliche Maßnahmen für die letzten zwei Spiele für nicht ausgeschlossen.
Also du hast gerade schon gesagt Darmstadt, ich habe eben schon mal gesagt, dann hat man das letzte Heimspiel ist gegen Ulm. Das ist halt, also ich glaube, da gab es ja im Vorhinein schon so ein absolutes Ticket-Chaos, wenn ich mich da richtig erinnere. Also dass irgendwie die Garten für ein Gäste-Blog in freien Verkauf gegangen sind, auszusehen oder so. Also ich weiß es ehrlich gesagt nicht mehr genau. Und dann hast du aber noch, also noch mal, also Darmstadt, Ulm, also gerade Platz 12, Platz 16 und dann spielt man auch Auswärts entführt. So, Auswärts entführt. Das ist so, wir haben eben schon mal kurz überführt gespielt. Ganz komische Mannschaft, auch wieder in dieser Saison. So, die sind entweder ab dem Zeitpunkt gesichert, so oder die müssen irgendwie noch hoffen, dass sie nicht um Relegationsplatz spielen. Das ist dann auch so ein Do-or-Die-Spiel. Pff, weiß ich nicht. Also das ist, ich meine, wir sagen das eh auch immer wieder, kein Restprogramm von irgendeinem dieser, von Vereinen unten oder oben drin wird in irgendeiner Art und Weise dankbar sein. Aber das ist halt, pff, ich weiß es nicht. Und es ist also ein kleiner Fun-Fact, den ich mir immer noch so rausgesucht habe. Ich weiß, das ist immer so wenig aussagekräftig, aber ich habe mal nachgeguckt, wäre das Spiel nach 45 Minuten zu Ende? Wäre der HSV erster, Köln zweiter? Und könnt ihr raten, wer auf dem dritten Platz stehen würde, wenn das Spiel nach 45 Minuten zu Ende wäre?
Hertha.
Löwe?
Düsseldorf.
Der SSV Ulm. Ulm wäre dritter, der 2. Liga wird das Spiel nach 45 Minuten zu Ende sein. Andersrum, witzig, die letzten drei wären Braunschweig, Hertha und Regensburg. Paderborn wäre nur auf Rang 15. Also, es gibt einen Grund, warum das Spiel 90 Minuten dauert. Das finde ich schon manchmal ganz witzig zu sehen, wie dann sowas auch rausgehen könnte.
Ich hatte bei Hertha ein Extrem im Kopf, aber dann habe ich es falsch rum angewandt.
Es kann ja auch immer sein, gerade bei Ulm, die müssen in der letzten dreiviertel Stunde katastrophal sein und umgekehrt Paderborn hinten raus sehr gut, wofür das Elvesberg-Spiel dann gerade genau nicht steht. Aber gut, ausnahmbestetigend, bekannterweise die Regeln. Aber das fand ich auch irgendwie schon ganz interessant.
Unsere Platzierung wundert mich übrigens nicht in dem Zusammenhang, weil wir können meistens keine erste Halbzeit, und das hat sich auch erst vor kurzem mal geändert.
Ja, sowas kann sich aber immer ändern. Also ja, wie gesagt, es ist dann noch immer wichtig, was nach 90 Minuten steht, und damit zahle ich, bestimmt irgendwie so eine Spardose ein Euro rein. Aber es gibt ja noch so ein Thema abseits des Platzes Thomas, und zwar, also komplett unabhängig davon, wie diese Saison ausgeht. Marcel Janssen wird nicht erneut als HSV-Präsident kandidieren für die neue Saison. Ja, und es wäre schön, wenn man das jetzt ganz in Ruhe betrachten könnte, aber nein, es hat sich ein Altbekannter direkt angemeldet, dass er sich eventuell auf dieses Amt bewerben will. Und das ist Felix Magath. Und ja, wie schaust du denn generell unaufgeregt auf diese Präsidentenwahl?
Tatsächlich habe ich aber wirklich den Eindruck, dass das jetzt eher so im Hintergrund so eine Geschichte ist und dass sich alles voll auf den aktuellen Sport konzentriert. Das ist klar, das hat irgendwie dann, als die Meldungen um die Ecke kamen, so ein bisschen Aufsehen erregt. Aber Felix Magath selbst, und er tritt ja gemeinsam an mit Richard Goldz, die legen auch Wert darauf, dass man jetzt hier nicht irgendwie in der entscheidenden Saisonphase großartig Unruhe stiftet oder so. Ich muss sagen, ich bin da so ein bisschen zwielgespalten, was die Personalien an sich angeht. Klar, Felix Magath steht jetzt auch eher für erfolgreichen Fußball, beziehungsweise Fußballdenkweise aus dem Jahr 2009 oder so. Also ein bisschen vom Eindruck her ein bisschen aus der Zeit gefallen, aber deswegen hat er sich auch ein bisschen breiter aufgestellt mit Richard Goelz. Und es wird dann immer so angeführt, ja, das ist irgendwie ein machtgetriebener Mensch und einer, der, wie gesagt, aus der Zeit gefallen ist. Wenn ich mir aber die anderen Kandidaten ansehe, wüsste ich nicht. Ehrlicherweise kann man jetzt bewerten, wie man will, aber wo mehr Fußball-Expertise sein soll, wo mehr auch– wir haben ja gerade über das große Thema Leistungskultur geredet, so beim HSV, ich habe es angedeutet– dass einfach so diese letzte Überzeugung auch in, ja, in die eigenen Fähigkeiten und auch in die Größe des Klubs. Ich meine, am Ende des Tages ist es halt einfach, vom Umfeld her ist es einfach, ja, was Stuttgart und Frankfurt machen, kann der HSV auch. Da braucht man sich nichts vormachen. Dieser Verein ist aber von seinen Glaubenssätzen wirklich teilweise so kurios und irgendwie sich selbst verzwergend, dass ich– ganz ehrlich, also man hat jetzt die letzten Jahre viel gesehen, viel versucht, viel probiert. Felix Magath in dem Präsidentenamt als Aufsichtsratschef, als einer, der da wirklich auch in einem Aufsichtsrat voller Unternehmer, die gar keinen Fußballbezug haben, vielleicht dann so ein bisschen zumindest sieht, hey, wer sind denn eigentlich die operativen sportlichen Verantwortlichen, die diesem Verein wieder diese Kultur geben können, die es braucht, um gerade solchen Situationen standzuhalten wie gerade? Wenn ich mir die Alternativen ansehe, why not?
Thomas, woran machst du das sich selber verzwergefasst?
Ganz exemplarisch vielleicht eine Szene, an die ich mich immer ganz gut erinnere, eben nur exemplarisch auch hundertmal zu besichtigen gewesen. Also man hat vor zwei Jahren in der Relegation, glaube ich in Summe 6-1, auf die Schnauze bekommen vom VfB Stuttgart. Und das ist jetzt irgendwie kein Appell, irgendwie dann an die Fans, sich mit Reiterstaffeln oder so anzulegen oder Fackeln aufs Spielfeld zu werfen oder sonst was. Aber eine Mannschaft, die mal wieder zum erneuten Male an ihrem Saisonziel gescheitert ist, mit Applaus und Sprechkörn in die Saison zu verabschieden. Hier hinten hängen Trikots aus Italien. Ihr seht sie, der Podcast-Hörer nicht. Diese Kultur ist da einfach ausgeschlossen. Und ich finde schon, dass sich da irgendwie sowas verselbstständigt hat in den letzten Jahren beim HSV. Ja, wir sind irgendwie doch zufrieden in unserem wohligen Zusammengehörigkeitsgefühl. Und was dann noch dabei rausspringt, mal sehen. Aber ja, das ist einfach nicht genug. Und das setzt sich, finde ich, auf allen Ebenen irgendwie in diesem Club fort und ist da zu besichtigen.
Ich finde da tatsächlich ganz interessant, weil ich glaube gerade diese Redaktion gegen Stuttgart, das war ja sowieso dieses Jahr, wo man da eigentlich in Sandhausen schon den Ausstieg gefeiert hatte. Und dann kam halt noch das Ergebnis mit Heidenheim raus. Ich glaube, dass das halt schon– da würde ich sogar fast die Fans minimal in Schutz nehmen wollen und sagen, ich glaube, das war emotional so eine dermaßen Sondersituation. Also ich kann das schon verstehen, dass man sagt, man hat es ja eigentlich schon wenig geschafft. Dann ist Stuttgart aber auch kein klassischer Relegationsteilnehmer. Also wenn man dann mal überlegt, wohin die Reise danach ging für den VfB mit Europa und Vizemeisterschaft. Aber ich glaube, also keine Ahnung, ich wüsste nicht, wie ich als Fan damit umgegangen wäre. Also jetzt könnt ihr ja alle eine Strichliste führen. Ich weiß halt, wie hier letztes Jahr einfach, also natürlich war man nicht mit dem Ergebnis zufrieden, dass man am vorletzten Spieltag erst den Klassenerhalt in der dritten Liga festgemacht hat. Nach zwei Abstiegen in Folge folgte fast der dritte. Aber damals war trotzdem dieses so, okay, wir müssen jetzt einfach alle nur hier irgendwie zusammenstehen und gucken, dass wir nicht absteigen. Und in dieser Saison zählt dann Erfolg. Und da erwarten wir dann auch, dass ihr 38 Spieltage für den Ausstieg kämpft so ungefähr und dass ihr als Mannschaft agiert. Ich glaube schon, dass es manchmal auch Fan-Alz einfach schwierig ist, da dann adäquat zu drauf reagieren. Würde aber da direkt anschließen, einmal wollen Thomas, wie ist denn sonst die Beziehung zwischen Fans und da gerade organisierter Szene vielleicht und Verein? Weil also ich finde schon, dass da gerade in den letzten Wochen und Monaten auch durchaus durch Spruchbandbänder und Co ja durchaus auch immer wieder Kritik geübt wird. Ich glaube jetzt am Wochenende auch wieder mal wieder für die Ticketpreise, die eben zu teuer seien, aber auch ich glaube in Richtung irgendwelcher Projekte mit Springer und Co. Ich bin da leider zu wenig drin, aber wie würdest du denn da generell die Beziehung noch einschätzen?
Vielleicht noch mal ganz kurz anschließen an das. Also das war nur exemplarisch gemeint. Ich verstehe, dass es dann natürlich irgendwie auch Grautöne gibt, die dann dies oder das rechtfertigen. Aber solche Szenen hat man auch gesehen, wenn die keine Ahnung, 0-3 in Münster verlieren. Und da fehlt mir dann tatsächlich wirklich das Verständnis. Wie dem auch sei, Verhältnis-Fans-Verein. Ja, wie du schon sagst, sind aber trotzdem dann immer so Fan-Themen, die dann irgendwie dann da irgendwie leidenschaftlicher debattiert oder ja, vielleicht auch ein bisschen mehr als das werden. Da gab es dann eben auch Treffen offenbar mit der Vereinsführung, über die Ticketpreise geredet. Das sind aber alles immer nur so Fan-Themen, die total ihre Relevanz haben, möchte ich gar nicht bestreiten. Aber man hat hier einen potenziellen Giganten des deutschen Fußballs, der im 7. Zweitliga-Jahr steckt. Und das sind dann irgendwie die Themen, die dann auch in dieser Saisonphase alles überlagern von Seiten der organisierten Fanszene. Ich weiß nicht. Also ich persönlich kann damit echt wenig anfangen.
Ja, ich bin mal wirklich gespannt. Ich glaube wirklich, dieses Ulmspiel könnte wirklich interessant werden, weil ich habe doch auch das Gefühl, dass– ja, das klingt immer so hart– aber nochmal so eine andere Stufe der Eskalation auch irgendwie da ist oder da sein könnte in dem Fall. Also wenn du das halt wirklich– vielleicht, wie du schon sagst, das ging halt wirklich von der Mannschaft auf die Fanszene von über. Ich bin mal gespannt, je nachdem, was jetzt in diesen nächsten beiden Spielen passiert. Weil man muss dann einfach sagen– ich sage das und ich weiß, dass genug Leute mich da auch bestimmt recht für kritisieren– ich glaube einfach dieses Problem, was der HSV hat, ist, dass man in diesen sieben Jahren immer ja nicht irgendwo nach 25 Spieltagen wusste, wir werden mit dem Aufstieg nichts zu tun haben. So, ganz klar. Sondern es war ja immer dieses, bis zum letzten Spieltag war so mehr oder weniger, also zweimal durch Relegation natürlich brutal gegen Hertha und gegen Stuttgart, aber es war immer ja so eine Resthoffnung eigentlich, bis zu langer Zeitvorschluss da. Und ich glaube halt einfach, das ist in der Saisonbewertung dann auch so schwierig. Also, was willst du da denn irgendwann machen, auch als Fan? Sagen so, ja hier, keine Ahnung, müssen wir vielleicht einmal eine Saison gegen den Abstieg spielen? Und dann wird's wieder und dann wird dir alles umgekrempelt. So, das ist ja... Also, ich gehe davon aus, dass du enorm viele Leistungsträger verlieren könntest im Sommer, wenn's jetzt wieder nicht geht. Also, klar, wurde mit allen möglichen Leuten verlängert, aber wir wissen alle, wie so Ausstiegsklauseln heutzutage funktionieren. Also bin ich schon... Also, nicht, dass ich denen das wünsche, aber genug Fragezeichen sind, glaube ich, in jedem Fall da.
Ja, ich glaube auch, also wenn es dieses Mal nicht klappt, bei der Ausgangslage, das ist ja wirklich eine deutlich bessere Ausgangslage, als man sie je hatte, weil drei, vier Spieltage vor Schluss war der HSV dann eigentlich schon immer in der Verfolgerrolle zurückgefallen, nachdem man vielleicht eher gegen Winter noch der absolute Topfavorit oder Tabellenführer war. Ich glaube, das könnte wirklich was mit dem Verein machen, vielleicht auch etwas Notwendiges machen. Ich weiß nicht genau, das wird sich zeigen. Es wird jetzt ganz viel auf dieses Darmstadt-Spiel ankommen. Und wie gesagt, ich glaube, je nachdem, wie das ausgeht, je nachdem, wie auch der Auftritt der Mannschaft ist, je nachdem, ob die wieder so ängstlich sind, dann liegen tatsächlich auch, glaube ich, für die letzten zwei Spiele echt alle Optionen auf dem Tisch. Und so leid es mir für den sympathischen Merlin Polzin tun würde, aber letztendlich hilft dann ja auch nur noch eine Kopfwäsche. Also irgendein Trainer, der Missionen kann, der einfach irgendwie die Köpfe nochmal frei kriegt. Der HSV hat es ja irgendwie auch vor drei, vier Jahren versucht, muss ich nochmal nachrechnen, als Daniel Thun eben kurz vor Saisonende gehen musste, mit Horst Rubesch. Und das wird dann immer von vielen auch in Debatten als Beleg dafür eingeführt, dass es nicht geklappt hat. Weiß ich nicht, glaube ich. Der HSV hat, glaube ich, einen Zweier-Punkt-Schnitt in drei, vier Spielen dann gehabt. Das war eigentlich völlig in Ordnung. Und wenn es dann eben nach dem Spieltag nur noch darum geht, vorne zu bleiben und nicht irgendwie was Aussichtsloses noch irgendwie zu schaffen, muss das halt vielleicht dann auch the way to go sein. Mal sehen.
Thomas, mal Worst-Case-Szenario. Der HSV scheitert wieder. Was ist denn aus deiner Sicht, in jedem Fall, ich hoffe, ich nehme jetzt keine Frage, welche du stellen wolltest. Was ist denn aus deiner Sicht nötig, um die Aufstiegswahrscheinlichkeit mal zu erhöhen? Also brauchst du Spieler, die ja natürlich Qualität mitbringen müssen, aber die eher stressresistent sind. So was ist ja angesprochen. Ein Trainer, der das hinkriegt, also der genau in solchen Crunch-Times das letzte aus dem Team rauskitzeln kann, brauchst du noch einen zusätzlichen Psychologen für das Thema? Was ist aus deiner Sicht das, was da eigentlich getan werden muss?
Eine Psychologin hat man. Das mit den stressresistenten Spielern mahne ich ehrlich gesagt schon seit zwei, drei Jahren an. Man hat es eben einfach nicht getan. Einfach auch, um die Hierarchie so zu wahren. Und ich glaube, man hat einfach auch die Hierarchie falsch eingeschätzt. Und was man halt sonst braucht, ja, entweder einen Exorzisten oder eben dann einen wirklich, wirklich sehr, sehr konstruktiven und klaren Sportvorstand. Also Stefan Kunz kann jetzt eben vielleicht auch in der Phase mit seiner Spielerfahrung helfen. Er hat aber, finde ich, auch bei vielen Themen jetzt keine so sonderlich gute Figur abgegeben. Da war eben, wir haben ja kurz über Lukas Quasniok geredet, vor der Winterpause ja eine ganz, ganz lange offene Trainerfrage, wo man sich dann erst noch mal irgendwie ganz, ganz eilig nach einem schlechten Spiel gegen Ulm überall Informationen eingeholt hat und Angebote rumgeschickt hat. Und dann hat das alles nicht geklappt. Und dann hat man auf einmal so getan, als wäre Merling Polzin immer schon die erste Wahl gewesen. Das stimmt einfach nicht. Und eine größere Souveränität einfach in diesen strategischen Fragen.
Ich habe noch eine persönliche Frage und zwar nach Immanuel Varei, weil der ja bevor zu euch kam in Braunschweig groß aufgespielt hatte und ja auch mit großen Hoffnungen, glaube ich, von den HSV-Fans begrüßt wurde. Kommt jetzt wenn überhaupt so von der Bank mittlerweile? A. Zurecht, weil das habe ich jetzt nicht so intensiv verfolgt. Und B. Das ist eigentlich ein stressresistenter Spieler, weil der kennt einen Abstiegskampf aus Braunschweig, also noch eigentlich ein viel höherer Druck. Wie kommt es, dass der jetzt nicht so ein bisschen Hoffnungsträger nochmal ist? Gerade weil er auch Fußball spielen kann, wenn er normalform erreicht.
Ja, ich muss auch sagen, dass ich ziemlich viele Erwartungen in dem hatte, als er kam. Er hat es immer wieder aufblitzen lassen, aber auch durch WW-Verletzungen. Er hat immer auch sehr, sehr anstrengende Länderspielreisen. Ich glaube, der ist da irgendwie auch immer 40 Stunden oder so. Ich spitze jetzt auch hier ein bisschen zu unterwegs. Er hat einfach nie seinen Rhythmus gefunden. Und ja, ich weiß auch nicht, also das harmoniert irgendwie auch nicht so mit den Mitspielern und auch von seiner Spielweise her, weil er ja doch bei Braunschweig sehr, sehr risikoreich einfach spielen durfte. Also der konnte probieren. Ich glaube, der hatte so eine exorbitant hohe Fehlpass-Statistik auch, weil er einfach immer vertikal gedacht hat. Und das war gerade das Problem dann eben auch bei Tim Walther oder unter Tim Walther. In diesem ballbesitzorientierten Fußball muss er noch sehr, sehr viel mehr irgendwie so das archaische Element, nenne ich es mal, in seinem Spiel irgendwie ein bisschen rausnehmen. Und er kann einfach nicht so sehr ins Risiko gehen, sondern muss hier nochmal einen Dreieck bilden und so. Und das scheint einfach irgendwie nicht so 100 Prozent zu harmonieren.
Wobei er mal sagt, als er nach Hamburg ging, naja, das ist ja auch eine offensiv aufgestellte Mannschaft. Er ist ja nochmal Offensivspieler in Braunschweig, aber er hat ja sehr viel defensiv arbeiten müssen. Also das würde ihm eigentlich mehr liegen, da wo er jetzt hingeht. Deshalb finde ich schon spannend, diese Aussage, die du da tätigst.
Ja, wie gesagt, ich hätte es wahrscheinlich auch am Tag seines Transfers und nach zwei, drei wirklich guten Spielen zu seiner Anfangszeit auch ein bisschen anders erwartet, dass es anders läuft.
Gut, aber ich würde fast sagen, wir lassen jetzt den HSV mal hinter uns, weil ich glaube, wir haben schon ganz gut aufgezeigt, ja, vielleicht was Probleme sind, lösen können wir sie von hier aus sowieso nicht. Aber ich glaube, alle wissen, das Spiel gegen Darmstadt, das könnte der Knackpunkt der Saison werden. Und wo die einen diese Liga unbedingt verlassen wollen, möchten andere Vereine einfach nur ganz, ganz gerne da drin weiter drinnen bleiben. Und das ist Eintracht Braunschweig. Die stehen momentan auf Platz 15, haben 34 Punkte, 35 zu 55 Tore. 8 Siege, 10 Unentschieden, 13 Niederlagen. 5 Punkte Vorsprung. Es sind es momentan auf Ulm und Münster auf Platz 16 und 17. Die sind ja punktgleich. Und ein Punkt hinter, die der Spielvereinigung führt, auf Platz 14. Und der Trainer ist natürlich weiterhin Daniel Scherning. Am Wochenende gab es ein 1 zu 1 bei Jan Regensburg. Ich glaube, das ist ein Ergebnis, mit dem dann doch hinten raus Braunschweig ein bisschen besser leben konnte als Regensburg. Und generell muss man einfach sagen, läuft es momentan bei der Eintracht. Die letzte Niederlage, die war gegen Hertha am 26. Spieltag. Gut, das war ein 1 zu 5. Aber Löwe, man hat so das Gefühl, seitdem hat sich Braunschweig durchaus gefestigt. Würdest du mir dazu stimmen?
Ja, die Zahlen sprechen ja für sich. Da würde ich dir auf jeden Fall zustimmen. Man muss dazu sagen, zu unserer aller Überraschung. Weil du sprichst ein großes Wort gelassen aus. Also nach dem 1 zu 5 zu Hause gegen Hertha war die Stimmung eigentlich nicht so, zumindest bei mir. Und ich glaube, das ging relativ vielen Fans auch so, dass da außer Hoffnung noch irgendwas war. Die Hoffnung stirbt zuletzt. Ich ergänze deinen Phrasenschwein. Die ist immer da, weil, wie man jetzt auch sieht, im Fußball kann immer irgendwie alles passieren. Aber der Glaube daran war überhaupt nicht mehr vorhanden. Also der Glaube war bei mir weg, als dann noch die Entscheidung kam, dann war ja Länderspielpause, dass Daniel Scherning Trainer blieb, weil er aus meiner Sicht bis zu diesem Zeitpunkt das Team 0,0 weiterentwickelt hatte. Also wir haben ja, du hast das Torverhältnis angesprochen, wir haben ja diverse Klatschen. Also das wäre nicht das einzige Spiel mit fünf Gegentoren. Das war das fünfte Spiel, glaube ich, mit fünf Gegentoren, das vierte oder fünfte. Da war kein Glauben vorhanden, gerade, dass er diesen Turnaround noch hinbekommt. Also ich bin da ganz ehrlich, ich mag erst mal Daniel Scherning als Typen sensationell. Der hat uns auf jeden Fall auch, man verzeiht mir die Ausdrucksweise, letzte Saison absolut den Arsch gerettet. Da war er genau der Richtige, um da den Karren auch aus dem Dreck ziehen zu können. Dann ging es aber überhaupt nicht weiter. Und bei mir innerlich war so, okay, da bleibt weiter Trainer. Warum soll das jetzt auf einmal besser werden? Ich meine, wir reden nach, ich weiß nicht, welches Spieltags war gegen Hertha. Wir reden immer noch über Flanken, die nicht ankommen, über Pässe, die nicht ankommen, über defensive Stabilität, die nicht vorherrscht, über keine Ideen in der Offensive. Was zum Kuckuck soll denn jetzt in den letzten Spielen sich da auf einmal dran ändern unter diesem Trainer? Und siehe da, es änderte sich und zwar so ziemlich alles. Also es gibt Erklärungen, aber so eine richtige Erklärung gibt es auch wiederum nicht.
Ja, also vor allem muss man ja sagen, also wir reden danach, man ist momentan das formstärkste Team der Liga aus den letzten fünf Spielen, gemeinsam mit der Hertha, also 11 Punkte aus den letzten fünf Spielen, 11 zu 6 Tore. Und ich glaube, das ist das, was einen da ja auch rausgezogen hat. Man hat gegen Paderborn, den HSV und Kaiserslautern gewonnen. Das sind die drei Spiele, die man nacheinander gewonnen hat. Und jetzt eben mal wieder ein Unentschieden gegen Regensburg. Gut, man könnte jetzt sagen, dann vielleicht lieber gegen Regensburg gewinnen, weil es halt die Distanz auch da nochmal höher stellt. Aber bei sie muss man ja sagen, also gerade auch dieses Spiel gegen HSV haben wir jetzt eben schon mal angesprochen, aber vor allem aus HSV-Sicht. Aber also das war ja, man führte ja und dann hatte man nach dem 2-1 kurz Angst, so jetzt wird das irgendwie seinen gewohnten Gang gehen dann doch. Und man hat dann ja aber nach der Halbzeit, man ist ja drangeblieben. Und das fand ich durchaus so respekt. Ich glaube, ich habe Anna danach auch geschrieben so, hey Glückwunsch, wo kam das jetzt her? Und gerade auch eben diese Siege gegen Paderborn und Kaiserslautern, also gerade wenn du gegen Kaiserslautern so ein bisschen die Statistiken dir anguckst, das liegt immer auch gegen Regensburg. Das ist eigentlich immer so die XG-Werte, das Torschuss für Hennes ist eigentlich immer relativ auf einer Höhe. Aber zum Beispiel in der FCK hat man eine komplette Halbzeit vom Tor weggehalten. Und dafür, dass man– also man lässt die meisten Schüsse der Liga zu, so 466. Wenn ich das richtig nachgeguckt habe, man hat immer noch die drittschlechteste Defensive der Liga. Also man ist jetzt nicht gerade irgendwie mit einem Wunder daraus gekommen. Aber ja, irgendwas musste ja wirklich passiert sein.
Also ja, es sind diverse Dinge passiert. Es ist für mich trotzdem am Ende des Tages keine echte Erklärung. Also wir können das gerne einmal aufdröseln. Also die Entscheidung wurde begründet damit, also vom sportlichen Geschäftsführer Benny Kessel, dass das, was Daniel Scherning präsentiert hat, was er jetzt vor Ort mit dem Team, dass das genau praktisch das gewesen wäre, was ein neuer Trainer auch gemacht hätte. Damit stand für ihn zumindest fest, dann ergibt das für ihn keinen Sinn, da einfach nur einen neuen Trainer zu installieren. Weil zwischen dem Team– und das ist auch etwas, was ich jederzeit glaube, zwischen ihm und dem Trainer– kein Blatt Papier passt. Okay, wir machen das jetzt anders, Jungs. Ärmel hochkrempeln und auf geht's. Und ich zeige euch jetzt, was die neue Idee ist, dass das Team da voll mitzieht. D'accord. Allerdings war das Spiel gegen Paderborn, auch wenn es gewonnen wurde, 60 Minuten lang alles andere als irgendwie gut. Also da hat man nicht viel gesehen. Man hat auch in dem Spiel, ohne den Sieg kleinreden zu wollen, auch einiges an Spielglück gehabt. Grimaldi kurz zu Schluss, der allein auf Hoffmann zurent und das Ding halt knapp neben den Pfosten setzt. Also es hätte auch gerne einen Unentschieden ausgehen können. Aber eine Komponente kam rein in der 60. Das war halt Bell Bell, der gegen einen völlig indisprimierten Bar eingewechselt wurde und plötzlich kippte dieses Spiel. Also das war wirklich mit dieser Einwechslung auf einmal auf unserer linken Seite jemand, der einfach Bock hatte, nach vorne zu spielen. Also warum Bell Bell genau in diesem Spiel auf einmal so auftaute, während er vor ein halbes Missverständnis war in Braunschweig, weiß halt auch kein Mensch. Was Scherning halt gemacht hat, ist er taktisch umgestellt. Also hat vor dem Regelfall ein 3-4-3 spielen lassen, hat auch so ein 5-3-2 umgestellt, also hinten wirklich dicht gemacht. Das hat halt auch gut funktioniert. Hat eine alte Braunschweiger Tugend wieder aufleben lassen, nämlich Umschaltspiel. Hat dazu jetzt auch Spieler keine Angst zu großen Namen gehabt. Er hat Ermin Bicakcic, Kapitän, auf die Bank gesetzt. Das ist eine Legende in Braunschweig. Hat dafür Köhler, was vorher auch, was er so ein Sechser war, dem er zwischenzeitlich noch einen Adjutanten an die Seite stellen musste. Meistens hat der Krause neben ihm gespielt, weil er auf der sechsten Defensiv meist etwas überfordert war. Er ist viel auf Köhler ausgerichtet, ohne dass er viel in der Offensive gebracht hätte. Jetzt hat Köhler plötzlich in die Innenverteidigung gesetzt, wo ein Hörer sagt, das klappt aber hervorragend, ist defensiv stark und er sagt selber, Köhler, ich habe das Spiel vor mir, das liegt mir einfach mehr. Er hatte zwischenzeitlich Philipp eine Auszeit gegönnt, seitdem dreht er auch wieder auf. Tetschi, auch plötzlich Effizienz-Explosion, ich würde es noch nicht mal Leistungsexplosion nennen, Ritt Müller, der auch lang mit Verletzungen gekämpft hatte, auch plötzlich in der Form seines Lebens grauset, er immer wieder abgeschrieben war, plötzlich so die stabilisierende Sex, also genau das Bindeglied dazwischen. Wir haben natürlich Glück mit Tempelmann. Das ist, ich habe es bei mir im Podcast gesagt, das für mich größte Rätsel der Winter-Transfer-Geschichte, und zwar auf einer globalen Basis, dass Schalke den hat gehen lassen, weil der ist in Braunschweig eingeschlagen wie eine Atombombe. Seitdem haben wir plötzlich einen Spieler, also der hat wirklich Spiele, das ganze Team mitgerissen, einfach durch seine Offensivdynamik. Das haben Gegner dann irgendwann ein bisschen eingefangen. Jetzt hat er sich auch daran gewöhnt, dass er wieder aufgetaucht wird und plötzlich funktioniert dieses Gesamtkonstrukt. Dieses Spiel in Hamburg– sorry Thomas, dass ich da aufhören muss– das hat mich und nicht nur mich völlig fassungslos gemacht. Auch wenn der HSV natürlich nicht seinen besten Tag hatte, aber das war eine Leistungsexplosion von Eintrott, die ihnen einfach überhaupt niemand, auch die eigenen Fans, nicht zugetraut hatte. Und klar, Fußball findet im Kopf statt. Die nächsten 5 Euro ins Phrasenschwein bringt das Selbstbewusstsein mit sich. Auch bei Miekel, der irgendwie, bevor er jetzt wieder Innenverteidiger Gott wurde, auf der Tribüne saß. Und plötzlich schnippt, dreht er auf. Es gibt Erklärungsansätze, es gibt taktische Muster, die geändert wurden, es gibt personelle Änderungen, die Sinn ergeben. Aber die Summe dieser Einzelheiten erklärt für mich nicht diese Leistungsexplosion. Gar nicht. Und das ist das größte Rätsel für mich. Nehme ich aber natürlich sehr gerne mit.
Weil du vorhin nach einem Gamechanger bzw. Saisonchanger gefragt hast mit Blick auf dieses Braunschweig-HSV-Spiel, war das andersherum vielleicht dann auch so ein bisschen so? Ja.
Also der glückliche Sieg gegen Pada Born war so ein bisschen okay. Jetzt haben wir mit dem Trainer, also haben wir den Trainer nicht verlängert. Stimmt ja nicht. So haben wir den Trainer nicht rausgeworfen, also gegen jegliche Branchengewohnheit. Mit Glück hat das Team das zurückgezahlt, indem es also wirklich nicht durch fußballerische Mittel, sondern durch puren Willen dieses Spiel irgendwie gewonnen hat. Muss wirklich sagen irgendwie. Also das ist ein Spiel, das musst du nicht gewinnen und das zeigt eine gesunde Mentalität in diesem Team, dass sie das geschafft haben. So und mit dem Wissen plus offenbar einen sehr ausgeklügelten taktischen Plan, wie eigentlich schon im Hinspiel. Und dieses Glauben, okay, durch Wille. Und wenn wir das so machen, wie der Trainer uns das sagt, so ein neuer Ansatz hinten dicht, schnell umschalten. Wir haben ein kompakteres Mittelfeld, dass wir drei Defensive da haben. Hinten stehen fünf. Mit dem richtigen Personal, das musst du erstmal überwinden. Und ja, dann, ich glaube, dieses 1 zu 0 von Bell Bell, das war wirklich so dieser That's Click gemacht in der Birne. So, aber selbst der Anschlusstreffer von Selke, also früher ein Gegentor, brach das Team gefühlt jedes zweite Mal halb auseinander. Und genau, Eva, wie du es gesagt hattest, das Gegenteil war, die haben einfach stuhl ihren Plan weiterverfolgt, haben weiter dran geglaubt und haben dieses wunderschöne dritte Tor dann hingelegt, was für mich– ich habe das in der Gegend gerade in meinem Podcast ein Gesamtkunstwerk genannt, weil das alles so unfassbar leicht aussah, aber alles andere als leicht war, dieses Tor. Und das hat– ja, das war so ein Game-Changer. Und ich glaube, der Zeitpunkt war wirklich das 1-0 von Belbel, wo wir sagen, okay, das funktioniert heute irgendwie.
Ja, das war eines der Spiele– es sind gar nicht so viele, glaube ich, in der Saison, die ich nicht im Stadion verfolgt habe. Habe ich nur dann im Fernsehen geguckt, wo ich mich gefragt habe, wo hat eigentlich Braunschweig so diesen Mut einfach auch hergenommen? Der war auch irgendwie über den Bildschirm hinweg zu greifen. Also ich bin jetzt wirklich kein Braunschweig-Experte oder so. Ich sehe sie auch ehrlich gesagt nur sehr, sehr selten spielen. Aber damit habe ich sie jetzt ehrlich gesagt nicht unbedingt zwingend in Verbindung gebracht und gerade dann in den Volkspark zu fahren und ja so einen Auftritt hinzulegen.
Das ist das, was ich etwas ausschweifend gerade versucht habe zu erläutern, auf den Punkt gebracht. Jetzt weiß man, wer hier der Journalist im Raum ist. Genau das, Thomas, der Mut. Weil es gab Situationen, das 2 zu 0. Das war natürlich ein Glückstreffer, gar keine Frage. Dass Jäcke seine alte Form wiedergefunden hat und riecht, wo kann ich auf einen Mann gehen und einen Ball erobern. Das war erst mal individuelle Qualität. Aber dass er dann ganz energisch den Weg nach vorn gesucht hat, das ist neu. Und das ist auch genau das, wo keiner so richtig eine Erklärung für hat. Wo kommt dieser Mut auf einmal her? Weil das typische Spiel– ich hatte vorhin darüber geredet, dass wir lange Spiele keinen erkennbaren Offensivplan hatten. Und da sah oft so aus, entweder lange Ball auf Polter oder Chabo nach vorne, oder wir wissen eigentlich nicht so richtig. Das gipfelte darin, dass einer wie Philipp, der nun Raum vor sich braucht und anspiele, dass er einen Gegner vernaschen kann oder in den Sprint gehen kann, dass er sich Bälle aus dem defensiven Mittelfeld geholt hat, weil vorne einfach nichts mehr ankam. Typischerweise war das Spiel alles andere als vertikal angelegt. Idealtypisch, dieser Lauf von Jäckl hätte früher nicht stattgefunden. Er hätte abgestoppt, erstmal nach hinten spielen, erstmal Ball sichern. Und wo das herkommt, das weiß kein Mensch. Das ist wirklich so ein Schalter umgelegt. Wir spielen jetzt mal mutig. Ich weiß, ob es verreckt nicht, oder ob es auf einmal herkommt.
Ja, sehr perfekt für die Zuhörer. Ich kann den HSV nicht erklären, du kannst Eintracht Braunschweig nicht erklären. Es sind irgendwelche größeren Mächte.
Wobei ich da in der glücklicheren Lage lag.
Aber sind wir mal auch ganz ehrlich, am Ende des Tages ist es ja auch schön, weil wir alles durch einfache Erklärungen zu erklären werden. Wow, perfekt.
Versteht uns nicht falsch. Ich genieße das gerade absolut.
Ich glaube, ich weiß nicht, ob das natürlich auch mit reinspielt, aber ich glaube, der Vorteil, den man irgendwie auch hat, das ist ja auch so wie, ich glaube, vor zwei Jahren damals auch war, dass so ein bisschen mehr auch große Teams da unten mit drin stecken. Also klar ist Braunschweig einfach qua Liga-Zugehörigkeit seit einigen Jahren. Auch wird einem ein bisschen was erwartet, gerade eben gegen die Aussteiger von unten, die sich jetzt trotzdem gerade 16, 17 und 18 belegen. Aber weil du eben auch so Schalke und Hertha da unten mit drin hast, hat man glaube ich vielleicht da wirklich so psychologisch doch den gleichen, den kleinen Vorteil gehabt, dass eben doch mehr auf die Vereine gucken und dass die sich da meistens, also dass die ja auch bis jetzt quasi noch, oder auch Darmstadt, also du hattest mehr auch von diesen Teams, die sich vor der Saison was ganz anderes vorgestellt haben oder die einfach woanders hin müssen auch. Klar, das beschreibt jetzt nicht vollends den eigenen Spielverlauf, aber ich könnte mir halt vorstellen, dass das irgendwie, dann sagst du ja okay, aber im Vergleich zu denen, haben wir eben doch ein bisschen weniger zu verlieren und können ein bisschen mehr probieren. Und ich weiß nicht, ob das vielleicht auch noch ausschlaggebend, und du hast halt ehrlich gesagt gesehen, also so viele Trainer-Entlassungen haben halt auch trotzdem nicht gewirkt. Also das muss man ja einfach noch sagen. Also ja klar, Ulm hat einen Trainer entlassen, Regensburg hat einen Trainer, gut, Ulm, also mit Ulm und Münster müssen wir eh so ein bisschen rausrechnen. Aber guck dir doch härter an, guck dir, Darmstadt steht im Endeffekt auch wieder da, wo sie damals mehr oder weniger ihren Trainer entlassen haben. Klar, mit einer bisschen besseren Form auch in manchen Spielen, aber trotzdem, so richtig geholfen hat es ja irgendwie auch nicht. Und dann muss man natürlich auch sagen, von den allen verfügbaren Trainern, ich weiß, dass ich das sehr häufig hier sage, aber erst mal musst du den passenden Trainer finden und der muss auch zu dir kommen wollen. Und du musst das Finanzielle noch beachten. Also es ist immer so, ich verstehe mal alle Seiten, ich war auch etwas fassungslos darüber, gebe ich auch gerne zu, weil ich ja auch meine persönliche Beziehung zu Daniel Scherning habe. Aber ja, also da muss dann ja auch, ich glaube, wenn dann so eine komplette Mannschaft da steht und sagt so, ne, ne, wir packen das aber auch mit dem. Das ist halt psychologisch, again, das Wort, aber das ist halt ein unfassbarer Vorteil, den du dann hinten rauslässt.
Ja, also dass das nicht untergeht. Ich ziehe alle Hüte, die ich jemals hatte, vor Daniel Scherning, also dass er in der Situation so ein Turnaround hinbekommen hat, obwohl er so angenockt war. Wie gesagt, ich ganz persönlich hätte ich die Entscheidung treffen müssen. Ich hätte ihn gehen lassen, bin ich ganz ehrlich. Wie wir heute wissen, es gibt deswegen Leute, die für solche Entscheidungen bezahlt werden und nicht von außen schlau quatschen. Was vielleicht eben auch ein Glücksfall war, ist, dass dann eben die großen Teams kamen, weil es liegt uns halt, nicht den Ball zu haben. Also gegen Regensburg kommt prompt, haben wir mehr Ballbesitz, kommt da nichts mehr raus. Ist dann ein defensiv starkes Team, die auch sagen, nimm mal einen Ball. Wir sind hier die Umschaltmannschaft. Wir suchen das Spiel nach vorne über Umschaltmomente, geht das prompt in die Hose bei der Eintracht. Das kommt uns an der Stelle da halt auch entgegen. Dass ein HSV, ein paar der Boren, die eine Super-Spielanlage haben, auch Kaiserslautern bis zu einer gewissen Weise, die auch mit Acha und solchen Leuten oder auch Ritter superstarke Leute in der Offensive haben, das kommt uns entgegen. Wir stellen uns dahin, verteidigen stark, kriegen den Ball und können umschalten. So spielt ein Gegner à la Braunschweig gerade voll in Probleme. Deshalb bin ich jetzt mal sehr gespannt. Das Spiel gegen Düsseldorf, gut, die wollen auch aufsteigen. Die müssen vielleicht was machen. Das kommt uns wiederum eher entgegen.
Du hast gerade schon gesagt, das geht gegen Düsseldorf, danach gegen Elbersberg. Also zwei Teams, die durchaus noch ein Wörtchen mitzureden haben am Ausstieg. Elbersberg haben wir auch noch gesagt. Die haben, wie ich weiterhin finde, eine der attraktivsten Spielanlagen der Liga. Das geht immer so ein bisschen unter. Aber da bin ich auch gespannt, weil sie dann ja trotzdem nicht so der klassische Ausstiegskandidat sind. Also wie das Spiel wird, könnte ja für beide Seiten brutal wichtig werden. Also für Elbersberg im Ausstiegskampf und für Braunschweig im Abstieg, obwohl man ja auch sagen muss, sollte man das Spiel gegen Düsseldorf gewinnen, kann man ja eigentlich sagen, es ist ja fast die Sache durch.
Wenn wir es dann noch verkacken, wären wir selber schuld, ja. Aber ich meine, ich habe einen hohen Respekt vor Düsseldorf. Also wenn wir da nicht verlieren, wäre schon viel gewonnen. Klar, schlafe ich nachts ruhiger, werden wir das gewinnen, aber das wird verdammt schwer. Ich fürchte nämlich gegen Elbersberg, da bin ich nicht ganz bei dir, Eva. Also ich glaube, das ist wirklich so der Underdog, der einfach nichts zu verlieren hat. Wenn die einfach Bock haben, jetzt mal den Rest der Liga zu ärgern, denke ich, Mensch, prima, die da oben, die kriegen alle das Nervenflattern. Wenn wir nicht aussteigen, ja, wäre zwar schade, aber es rechnet ja irgendwie keiner mit uns. Also die haben, glaube ich, noch am ehesten Bock aufzusteigen, Spiele zu gewinnen und haben am wenigsten zu verlieren von allen, die da oben noch umschwören.
Ja, also zur Einordnung, ich meinte damit halt nicht der, also einer der großen Namen, also eben kein Köln, HSV, Metteburg, in dem Sinne, also die man vielleicht eher vor der Saison dahingesetzt hat und die dann natürlich auch von Anfang an mit einer anderen Spielanlage und mit einem anderen, ja, Selbstverständnis in dieses Spiel gehen, als es vielleicht andere Mannschaften machen. Also das war, deshalb sage ich, das wird vielleicht anders als die Spiele bisher. Aber also ja, also ich bin tatsächlich gespannt und eben als letztes, als Saisonabschluss Nürnberg, für die geht es da um nichts mehr. Also das können wir jetzt ja einfach, also ergehen, ja, rein rechnerisch ist da noch viel möglich, ich weiß, aber ich würde halt trotzdem sagen, die sind für mich da raus, ehrlich gesagt. Also ich würde wirklich spätestens bei Karlsruhe mit 47 Punkten, würde ich da tatsächlich den Cut machen, weil ich das einfach noch nicht sehe, dass Mannschaften mit mehr als 3 Punkten den Rückstand auf den Relegationsplatz da wirklich noch spielen, weil dafür sind da zu viele Mannschaften drin. Das gehört nämlich noch dazu. Ja, also da bin ich schon gespannt.
Schamant ist halt, am letzten Spieltag nehmen sich Münster und Umgänge, die Punkte weg. Also das kommt auch noch ein bisschen entgegen. Wobei Dinge oder Mannschaften spielen für Eintracht, unsere DNA ist so, dass das dann alle verkacken. Also bevor es nicht rechnerisch feststeht, gebe ich hier keine Entwarnung.
Ja, das ist sowieso immer besser, sich nicht auf irgendwelche Eventualitäten zu verlassen. Wir wissen alle, wie sowas laufen kann. Aber ich bin mal gespannt, weil ich glaube, Düsseldorf, die haben halt enorm gestruggelt. So gegen Ulm, gegen Münster, gegen Regensburg auch, wenn ich mich da jetzt richtig erinnere, in der jüngeren Vergangenheit. Also sie ist Münster-biel, glaube war ganz katastrophal über weite Strecken. Also ja, da bin ich auch mal gespannt, wie das wird. Aber generell, lass uns mal einmal schon so ein bisschen, weil also ich glaube über den ganzen Saison brauchen wir jetzt nicht nochmal zu gucken, weil das haben wir mit Anna auch schon zum Teil gemacht. Und wie du auch schon gerade gesagt hast, rein faktisch gesehen gibt es ja auch viele Sachen, die irgendwie dann auch lange nicht gut liefen. Man hat sich jetzt eben entschieden, mit Daniel Scherling erstmal weiterzumachen und sollte am Ende der Saison– ich spreche es jetzt aus, damit du es nicht aussprechen musst– wenn der Klassenerhalt steht am Ende der Saison. Ist ja trotzdem so ein bisschen die Frage, wie geht es denn im Sommer weiter? Macht man mit Daniel Scherling nochmal weiter, der dann wieder Last Minute oder mehr oder weniger Last Minute den Klassenerhalt geschafft hat und man jetzt glaube ich drei Jahre hintereinander immer zum Ende raus, dann den Klassenerhalt gerade noch so gemacht hat? Oder was passiert denn im Sommer? Weil also Stand jetzt, was aus der dritten Liga hochkommt, ist bei allem Respekt vor den drei Vereinen, vor Regensburg, Münster und Ulm, doch nochmal was anderes, wenn man statt jetzt sagt, es kommen irgendwie Dresden, Bielefeld und Cottbus hoch. Ja, alleine von der Stahlkraft durchaus nochmal was anderes, als das bisherige. Also was, zurück zu meiner Auskunft, was ist der Plan für den Sommer?
Ja, was ist der Plan? Die ganz große Gefahr ist, dass mit einer Klassenerhalt tatsächlich eingetütet wird, dass sich alle mal wieder auf die Schulter klopfen und sagen, na guck mal, haben wir doch wieder gut hinbekommen, wir wollen eigentlich nicht groß das ändern. Also, wenn man mal ein bisschen weiter zurückkommt, guckt seit 2018, dem damaligen sehr überraschenden Abstieg aus der 2. Liga, ging es ja hoch her bei der Eintracht, also rauf und runter, Berg- und Talfahrt, mit allerdings auch sehr vielen Tätern. Seit dem letzten Aufstieg ist ziemlich viel falsch gemacht worden im Verein. So, ich meine, du sagst es ja zu Recht, auf den allerletzten Drücker tüte nochmal wieder ein Klassenerhalt ein. Der gemeine Braunsteig-Fan sehnt sich nach so einem Mittelfeldplatz, so einer Saison, wo wir einfach sagen, hey, wir werden mal 11er oder so was, oder allzu große Abstiegsnöte. Es wurde eigentlich versucht, jetzt endlich mal im letzten Sommer, überhaupt mal ein Konzept zu entwickeln, nämlich, okay, wir holen mal verstärkt jüngere Spieler, die man entwickeln kann und später dann verkaufen kann. Das bringt uns auch unsere etwas maroten Finanzen vielleicht auch wieder in Ordnung und bringt uns perspektivisch in die Lage, auch mal wieder investieren zu können. Das ist halt durch den katastrophalen Fehlstart sofort wieder einkassiert worden. Das heißt, Daniel Scherning hat zwar junge Spieler gehabt, die hat aber nicht eingesetzt. Wir haben auch eine Menge Verletzungspech nach hinten raus in der Hinrunde gehabt, das muss man auch fairerweise dazu sagen. Aber es ist auch wieder die Situation, was natürlich auch richtig ist in so einer Situation, dass du dann Leihspieler holst. Dann hast du jemanden wie Tempelmann, einen riesen Glücksgriff. Aber natürlich setzt du dann auf diese bewährten Hautdegen, statt dass du da weiterhin junge Spieler einsetzt. Also der einzige, der jetzt so ein bisschen mehr Spielzeit bekommt, ist Max Marie. Das heißt, wir stehen eigentlich wahrscheinlich vor dem nächsten großen Umbruch vom Kader in der nächsten Saison. Ein bisschen besser, weil wir ja neue Spieler geholt hatten, die dann vielleicht auch mal wieder fit bleiben. Wir haben allerdings eh im Verein offensichtlich ziemige Unruhe. Die Warren-Schwester-Zeitung hat darüber jetzt mehrfach berichtet, dass der Aufsichtsrat da sich nicht grün ist, dass da Fraktionsbildung ist, dass bei der letzten Mitgliederversammlung eine Aufsichtsrätin nicht entlastet wurde, die dann so halbherzig, so halb vor die Tür gesetzt wurde, nämlich eigentlich gar nicht. Die war dann zwar nicht mehr Mitglied des Aufsichtsrats, ist aber weiter beratend tätig gewesen, hat auch Zugriff auf Freikarten gehabt und und und. Also eigentlich alles mitgenommen, was man an Privilegen genießt. Der Aufsichtsrat war offensichtlich auch treibende Kraft damals bei der Freistellung von Michael Schiele, obwohl er einen Klassenhalt geschafft hatte unter dem Vorwand, das ist Vorwand unter der Maßgabe, naja, er habe das Team ja nicht weiterentwickelt. Seitdem ist eigentlich immer noch nichts in Sachen Weiterentwicklung passiert. Lange Rede, kurzer Sinn. Also wenn Daniel Scherling es schafft und jetzt offensichtlicher schafft, auch spielerisch die Kurve zu kriegen mit dem Team, fände ich es fair, ihn weiter zu beschäftigen, bin ich ganz ehrlich. Das ist für mich ganz persönlich, wer aufmerksam zugehört hat, eine 180-Grad-Wendung, aber ich würde sagen, okay, der hat dann am Ende sehr spät nachgewiesen, er kriegt es doch hin, was ich ihm nicht mehr zugetraut habe. Gibt es uns verrecken keinen Grund, jetzt ihn zu entlassen und einen neuen Trainer zu holen, nochmal ganz von vorne anzufangen. Der hat jetzt seine Erfahrungen gesammelt, gibt ihm die Chance, macht da weiter. Wie das im Kader wird, wir werden eine Reihung für lieb, wenn wir die Klasse halten, verlängert sich der Vertrag automatisch um den Jahr, den werden wir für Braunstucker Verhältnisse relativ teuer verkaufen können. Dann besteht zumindest eine Chance, jemanden wie Tempelmann zu halten und vielleicht noch mal die eine oder andere Verstärkung zu holen. Sicherlich auch Benni Kessel, das ist jetzt seine erste Saison als sportlicher Leiter gewesen, wird jetzt auch seine Erfahrungen gemacht haben, darf auch Fehler machen, da ist er noch jung genug zu. Wenn er aus ihnen lernt, was passieren muss, es muss jetzt wirklich mal im gesamten Verein ein Konzept sichtbar werden. Wo wollen wir hin, was tun wir dafür? Was wollen wir mit der langsam marode werdenden Infrastruktur machen? Haben wir eigentlich sonst irgendwie eine Strategie mit diesem Verein? Weil das ist seit Jahren ein Leben von Hand in den Mund und die Fans haben darauf keinen Bock mehr. Wir sind wirklich, egal wann, immer 20.000 im Stadion, egal wie scheiße das Team spielt, bis auf so Ausnahmesituationen wie gegen Hertha, wo dann wirklich auch das letzte Mal der Kragen geplatzt ist, immer Unterstützung im Stadion, immer Langmut. Aber so langsam, Leute, müsst ihr mal liefern. Das muss passieren im Sommer. Und wenn das nicht passiert– und ich fürchte, mit diesem Aufsichtsrat wird das nicht passieren. Es läuft gerade eine Mitgliederversammlung, da kann ich nicht beiwohnen, weil ich gerne bei euch zu Gast bin. Ich bin gespannt, ob da die entsprechend mal unangenehmen Fragen auch mal thematisiert werden. Weil das Kommunikationsverhalten des Vereins ist unterirdisch seit Langem, also die Verlängerung mit Daniel Scherling, das war ein Fünfzeiler von Benni Kessel, mehr wurde da nicht gemacht. Da wurden solche Krisen überhaupt nicht moderiert. Es wird totgeschwiegen, was ein Kritik von der Braunschweizer Zeitung kommt. Und Leute, so geht es nicht weiter.
Ich finde es ja schon immer interessant, so unterschiedlich die Position und auch die Tabellensituation beim HSV und bei Braunschweig ist, dass man doch immer wieder sieht, dass da so grundsätzliche Fragen doch gestellt werden. Also was ist denn der langefristige Plan? Also wir müssen ja auch alle ehrlich sein, so fußballromantisch wie wir sind, zum Teil sind halt Fußballvereine doch in einem gewissen Fall halt Wirtschaftsunternehmen. Also natürlich, aber halt mit der Besonderheit, dass die Mitglieder da immer noch das in der Theorie das letzte Wort haben. Und also natürlich großes Dankeschön, dass du trotzdem bei uns bist und nicht bei der Mitgliederversammlung. Das ist klar, aber wie wichtig das auch nochmal ist, dass man wirklich da auch einfach nochmal der Appell, wenn ihr Mitglied im Verein seid, dann geht, außer ihr sitzt bei mir im Podcast, dann geht zu diesen Mitgliederversammlungen, geht zu den Jahreshauptversammlungen, so heißt es bei uns zumindest. Und ja, einfach ehrlich gesagt, um einmal auch raus aus der eigenen Fanbubble zu kommen, das ist ganz, ganz, ganz wichtig, glaube ich auch. Also, weil wir alle unsere Bubble haben, wenn man vor allem auch einfach nur Fan ist, oder vielleicht das so journalistisch nicht so begleitet. Und ja, nehmt halt einfach teil daran. Stellt kritische Fragen, organisiert euch da irgendwie, dass man das schafft. Weil ich glaube, es ist einfach, wir sehen zum Teil, wo das hinführen kann, wenn so was übernommen wird. Ganz, ganz liebe Grüße an 1860 München. So, und Co, also das ist, was da abgeht, ich glaube, das wäre Stoff für 80 Tribütengespräche für Max. So ungefähr, weil einfach da, ne, da merkst du einfach, faktisch haben die Mitglieder da halt einfach, wenigen noch mehr mitzureden. Da kann, also nächstes Mal geht es einmal bestimmen, wer sich, wer ihnen was da einabkauft. Und wenn es ihm nicht gefällt, dann behält er ihn. Super Idee. Ne, aber das ist einfach, also einfach der Appell. Macht's. Geht zu den Mitgliederversammlungen. Ich weiß, es macht keinen Spaß, auf einem Montagabend da 5 Stunden zu sitzen. Habe ich alle schon gemacht. Ist richtig uncool. Ist auch oft richtig cringe in manchen Momenten. Aber es ist trotzdem den großen, großen Vorteil, den wir egal, ob es 500 Mitglieder oder 50.000 Mitglieder sind, den wir einfach haben. Und ja.
Ich an der Stelle, sorry, weil du gerade 1860 München sagst, ich muss einmal Fremdwerbung betreiben, sei mir erlaubt. Es gibt einen sensationellen Podcast von der Süddeutschen Zeitung über 1860 München. Außerhalb des Rasenfunks der beste Podcast über Fußball, den ich je gehört habe. Also ich habe das so gefeiert. Ich habe es so geliebt. Thomas, gerne noch mal weitergeben. Kompliment an die Kollegen da. Fantastisch. Also wirklich, das hat Riesenspaß gemacht, ihn zu hören.
Der ist wirklich sehr, sehr gelungen. Also auch von mir eine dringende Hörempfehlung. Sehr, sehr gut. Könnte man auch mal über den HSV oder so machen.
Ja.
Stoff gibt es genug.
Und in den Show Notes verlinken. Weil, also, Podcastempfehlungen nehmen wir natürlich immer gerne.
Gut.
Löwe, liegt dir irgendwas noch zu deinen Löwen? Ich musste einmal den Wortwitz machen. Liegt dir da noch was auf dem Herzen? Entschuldigung.
Jungs, bringt das Ding über die Ziellinie. Ihr schafft das. Ich glaub wieder an euch. Ihr habt es geschafft. Ich glaub wieder an euch.
Das ist doch– it's the hope that kills you, ne? Um es frei nach Tetlas zu sagen. Sonst würde ich tatsächlich sagen, befinden wir uns am Ende dieser durchaus wieder langen Folge. Ich hab's am Anfang gesagt, es wird niemals passen, dass wir in der vorgeschriebenen Zeit fertig sind. Die Liga ist schuldig. Alle schuld, geht jetzt einfach nur noch an die Liga. Ich sehe mich unschuldig hier. Ich bedanke mich ganz, ganz herzlich für diese fantastische Runde. Einmal an Thomas Hürner von der SZ. Schön, dass du mal wieder dabei warst, um über den HSV zu reden.
Sehr gerne. Er hat mich auch sehr, sehr gefreut.
Und dann auch lieben Dank an seinen Rasenfunk-Debüt und für das Rasenfunk-Debüt an Thomas Löwe. Danke, Thomas, dass du auch da warst.
Danke schön. Aber ganz herzlichen Dank. Und ich hoffe, ich konnte Anna ja, würde ich vertreten.
Ich sag mal so, auf jeden Fall, weil ich hab die letzten Folgen sehr gerne auch mit Anna gemacht. Aber du warst auf jeden Fall eine würdige Vertretung. Und bevor ich euch jetzt in diese Folge entlasse, hab ich noch zwei Podcastempfehlungen, beziehungsweise zwei Medienempfehlungen an der Stelle. Einmal Sport Insight über Heinz Krügel und seine SS-Vergangenheit, aber auch um und wie das aufgearbeitet wird. Und eine ganz klare Höherempfehlung auch in Bezug auf die Aufarbeitung der NS-Arbeit in den Vereinen. Das finde ich eine große Empfehlung. Und auch da die Info, wenn es sowas bei euch im Verein noch nicht gibt, organisiert euch da auf jeden Fall. Der Kicker hat zum Beispiel unter anderem seine Online-Archivien einfach mal zur Verfügung gestellt. Und dann, weil es leider irgendwie im Thema ist, ist auch noch der Hinweis, dass Ruben Gergeco hat einen Text geschrieben über Rechtsextremismus und Fußball. Auch das ist ja immer wieder ein wichtiges Thema. Und daher auch dazu eine Empfehlung. Und wie gesagt, ich verlinke auf jeden Fall noch den 1860 Podcast.
In 1860 heißt er, ja.
Und auf jeden Fall auch nochmal, weil wir darüber jetzt so wenig gesprochen haben, aber eure Podcastfolgen Löwe mit Thorsten Lieberknecht. Für alle, die den nochmal mehr sehen wollen. So, jetzt bin ich hier aber auch wirklich durch, mit meinen Nerven bzw. mit meiner Fähigkeit, gerade Sätze rauszubringen. Lieben, lieben Dank fürs Zuhören. In zwei Wochen sitzt hier wieder Marc. Ich kann euch noch nicht sagen, welche Vereine. Es werden sich wieder irgendwann in Spotlight bringen. Aber bis dahin, viel Spaß mit Fußball, bleibt gesund und macht's gut.
Das war der Rasenfunk.
Wir freuen uns über ihre Unterstützung.
Lernst ein bisschen Geschichte und dann werden sie sehen, Herr Reporter, wie sich das damals im Parlament entwickelt hat.